No matter how big, expensive or complicated
a movie might get, it's still everyday people
making it - which means a ton ofmistakes,
errors, or oversights in even thebiggestbox
office hits. Nobody's perfect, but you'll
be amazed to find out just how manymistakesfans
are willing to ignore - or never even catch
in the first place. Here is Screen Rant's
Know Your Movies: The Biggest Mistakes In
FROZEN.
Properties Of Ice
The ice saws in the opening number are used
properly, but it would be impossible to start
by stabbing directly through ice that thick.
Ghostly Shadows
The shadows cast by Anna and Hans are fine,
but the silhouettes hovering in midair isn't.
Hair Clipping
Instead of pulling her braid over her shoulder
from behind, Elsa teleports the braid directly
through her shoulder.
Unfrozen Water
Anna's dip into an icy stream leaves her with
afrozensolid dress, but having seen a
fountain, and a waterfallfrozensolid,
there's no reason why the stream should still
be flowing.
Weather Woes
Aside from the snow, the weather is pretty
calm on the mountain. But that doesn't stop
the Trading Post door from being slammed violently
shut, or Kristoff stepping out of a blizzard.
Reindeer Nouns
The plural of "reindeer" is "reindeer," not
"reindeers." Having grown up around them,
you'd think Kristoff would know that.
Missing Tune
Kristoff's guitar clearly has four strings,
but only three tuning pegs.
Side By Side
Elsa's not the only user of magic. Kristoff's
sleigh has enough room for he and Anna to
share, but when she makes a point of moving
to the edge of her seat, the next shot puts
her back at his side, packed in closer than
ever.
Directionless
Kristoff and Anna are heading towards the
north mountain when she stops to look back
at Arendelle. With the camera flipped, they
should be heading camera right, but the north
mountain is revealed to be to the left, from
the same way they just came.
Head Hurt
When Anna and Kristoff run into Olaf, he winds
up with his head turned upside down. His view
should have their positions reversed, with
Kristoff and Sven on the right, but they're
on the same sides as the shot before.
Reflections
The ice columns reflect Anna's face with a
view from head-on, not to the side, which
they should.
The Hat Trick
The animators apparently forgot about Anna's
hat when she and Kristoff slide out of Elsa's
castle, since it magically reappears in the
next shot.
Got Rope?
Anna makes the right call in cutting herself
and Kristoff loose, but they're still tied
to one another - until they land, and the
rope is gone.
Royal Family
Hans charges Queen Elsa with treason while
acting as regent, even though most monarchs
can't actually be charged with treason against
the state, since they ARE the state. But his
entire plan was a bust, since the husband
of a queen doesn't become king if the queen
dies.
Hot And Cold
When the guards come to execute Queen Elsa,
they discover she'sfrozenher way out of
her shackles. The problem is that hot metal
bends - cold metal would shatter instead.
Ninja Feet
Kristoff and Sven leave a trail of footprints
when they leave Anna behind, but when turning
back for their rescue, the snow hasn't even
been touched.
Door Versus Doors
When we first see Queen Elsa's study, her
double doors fittingly open onto the end of
a long hall. But when Anna is later locked
in the same room, the double doors now open
onto a wall.
Secret Sword Sheath
Apparently Hans wields a magical sword, since
it appears and disappears throughout the movie,
including when he draws it from a make believe
sheath in the final act.
Block Magic
When Anna saves her sister's life, the power
knocks Hans unconscious, sliding behind a
block of ice a few feet away - that is completely
missing just seconds later.
Thumbs Down
Even Disney makesmistakes, including Kristoff's
thumb passing though Anna's digital clothing
for a split second.
There you have it: everymistake, error,
or inconsistency in Disney'sFrozen. We've
kept our list to only themistakesthat
are impossible to dispute, and we think fans
would agree that they're easy to forgive - even
if we have to spot each and every one of them
during our next viewing. Did we miss any of
your favorite slip-ups? Let us know in the
comments (and maybe what other movies we should
put under the microscope), and remember to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.